Bonjour, YouTube ça va ?
Ouais
Alors, ces derniers temps
Avec le Nouvel An et tout
J'ai fait pas mal de soirées
Avec mes potes
Et franchement à chaque fois, c'était vraiment une réussite
FAUX
Alors déjà les soirées ça se passe toujours comme ça
Houla !
Attendez, refaites voir un peu
Non, les gobelets rouges comme ça c'est dans les films américains
Nous en France, c'est des bons gobelets blancs des familles
Que t'as acheté chez Carrefour
Et avec un peu de chance, y'a ton prénom écrit dessus
Hein... Histoire de pas mélanger
Moi j'ai remarqué dans les soirées comme ça un peu moyennes
C'est toujours au moment où je me barre
Que l'ambiance décolle vraiment
Franchement, cette soirée elle est pétée, on se casse là
Ah c'est clair c'est nul
Yo what's up
I'm Wiz Khalifa
HOOOOOOOOOO
On est Anglaises, on a vu de la lumière dehors
Est-ce que c'est possible de passer la soirée avec vous ?
HOOOOOOOOOO (I speak English very well !)
On a bien fait de quitter cette soirée de merde
C'est clair
Hou hou
Eh les gars j'ai trouvé de la Marijuana sur le canapé !
Ouaaaaaaaaaaaaaah
Eh mes parents ont une piscine géante ! On va se baigner ! Vous êtes chaud ?
Ouais !
Concours de T-Shirt mouillés !
Ouaiiiiiiiiiis
On va rentrer, on va se faire un p'tit Fifa mon gars
Ouais
Ils vont être jaloux
Quand tu vas en soirée, l'objectif c'est quoi :
C'est danser, rigoler, s'amuser
Manger des chips
Pour certains vraiment c'est pas ça
Vraiment eux leur objectif
c'est :
Frère, ce soir je veux boire le plus possible
Je veux me mettre une énorme race
J'veux qu'dans mes veines coule de la Vodka pure
J'ai envie d'être le mec le plus bourré du monde
Tu comprends ça ou pas ?
Est-ce que tu comprends ?
Pour ce genre de mecs
Vraiment : Faire la fête = Détruire son corps
Bon en même temps y'a jamais un mec qui se dit :
On a eu le BAC
Ce soir on boit modérément !
On se met en dessous du seuil d'alcoolémiiiiie !
Qui c'est qui va rentrer en toute sécurité ?
C'EST NOUS !
Par contre, moi, c'est les clés de ma boîte aux lettres, ça compte ou pas ?
Ouais HAHAHAHA
C'est mieux de faire confiance aux autres
Hein pour organiser des soirées
Quand t'essayes d'organiser des soirées toi même
Euh bah on sait comment ça se passe
D'abord t'appelles ton meilleur pote
Il peut pas
Après t'appelles ton pote, un peu moins proche
Il n'est pas dispo non plus
Et de fil en aiguille t'appelles vraiment des mecs que tu connais de moins en moins
Ouais j't'avais acheté une perceuse sur LeBonCoin tu te rappelles ?
Ouais je sais pas, on avait déliré au moins ensemble pendant je sais pas moi deux minutes
Ca te dirait de faire une soirée
Allô, Allô Mr. Berger ?
(Cris de bébé) (Prout)
Alors, pour organiser des soirées
Moi, je laisse faire les autres
Mais y a toujours ce pote
Qui se prend pour un organisateur de soirées
Et qui veut te prouver qu'il a des contacts dans le monde de la nuit
Les gars ce soir, je vous emmène dans un club
Je connais le videur, le mec limite c'est un pote
Il va nous mettre une petite table avec des bouteilles
Je vais vous mettre extrêmement bien OK ?
Alors déjà, ne serait-ce que quand tu arrives devant la boîte
Euh t'y crois un peu moins
Putain c'est quoi ce plan de merde là
On fait la queue là !
Non mais ça c'est une queue VIP ça
Ouais mais c'est 200 VIP quand même !
Putain c'est quoi cette entrée là où les gens sont accueillis par le directeur sur un tapis rouge là ?
Ah mais ça c'est l'entrée des loosers... ça... c'est des gros nuls !
Ce sont des loosers qui rentrent vite quand même
J'aurais préféré être un looser
Je te connais toi
Moi je te connais pas moi
Toi tu me connais pas mais moi je te connais donc euh
Bah je te connais quoi
Bah non
Attend, y'...y'a une erreur là
Viens, je rentre 2 secondes à l'intérieur
Et je vois mon contact
Et j'nous fait rentrer
Allez casse-toi bouffon là !
OK, c'est bon ils sont hyper chauds
On a une table à nous à l'intérieur
Ah cool !
C'est juste que...
Bah quoi ?!
Bah y'a des gens dessus quoi
Putain..
Et ils partent quand ?
Demain
Donc euh
Donc ce soir .. ?
Y'a une petite boulangerie nocturne
qu'est sympa aussi !
Tout de façon moi j'aime pas sortir en boîte
Quand y a une table qui commande un max de bouteilles
Y'a toujours cette phase musicale où tout le monde doit s'arrêter de danser
Et admirer messieurs dames !
Les rois de mes couilles !
♫Thème de Star Wars♫ Ils ont commandé des Magnum de Vodka
On fait du bruit pour eux s'il vous plait !
Toi quand tu commandes ta vieille bière nulle
Tout seul en boîte
Y'a pas de musique
Ou alors pour la bière la moins chère de la boîte
À mon avis la musique ce serait plutôt
♫Thème de Benny Hill♫
C'est ma bière !
*soufflement*
Quand la soirée chez tes potes
est un peu nulle
Parfois y'a de gens qui font ce qu'on appelle une contre-soirée
Ils squattent la cuisine, la salle de bain
Et parfois y'a plus d'ambiance là que dans la soirée elle même
(Discussion)
C'est pas grave j'vais aller démouler un cake dans le salon
Alors on arrête pas de parler de soirées ratées
Mais parfois aussi la soirée est parfaite
Le lieu est parfait, le DJ déboîte
Le nombre de personnes invitées est idéal
Tout est parfait sauf un détail
EH CA VA TOUT LE MONDE OU PAS LA ?
Ah y'a pas de meufs ?
Bah ouais on est 45 mecs et y'a vraiment aucune meuf
Ah OK
Bah on fait quand même la fête ou ?
Ouais x 3
Encore moi
Avec la langue hein !
AH LA CHANCE !
Une soirée, on sait jamais vraiment quand elle finit tu vois
Pourtant y'a un élément déclencheur
Qui selon moi met vraiment un terme définitif à la soirée
C'est quand un groupe de filles se met à chanter des chansons Disney
Et si on mettait des chansons Disney
OUI
Ah bah c'est la fin de la soirée là !
Ce rêve bleu !
Vraiment très peu pour être heureux
Libérée, Délivrée
Sous l'océan Sous l'océan
Bah ils sont partis où les autres ?
Ah ouais d'accord, les mecs ils ont niqué l'ambiance quoi !
Peut-être c'est nous ?
Non..
Dans la famille des gâcheurs de soirées
Y'a aussi évidement les voisins
N'est-ce pas ?!
"Ta Gueule !"
Quand tu fais une soirée avec la musique hyper forte et que le voisin arrive c'est jamais pour dire :
Bonsoir
C'est le voisin
Est-ce que vous pouvez un petit peu augmenter le volume du son ?
Hein parce que moi j'adore l'Electro !
Les infrabasses qui vibrent bien dans le plancher
N'hésitez pas à vomir sur mon paillasson aussi ! Un vrai plaisir !
Prenez du plaisir les jeunes !
Quoi que
Je préfère le voisin chiant qui vient raller
Plutôt que les voisins bien lâches
Qui appellent les flics
La police !
Normalement ça doit intervenir dans des braquages de banque !
Des prises d'otages !
Qu'est-ce qu'ils viennent foutre avec leur flingue à la ceinture
Dans une soirée posée entres potes ?
Pose tout de suite ce curly !
J'ai pas envie de plaisanter !
Romain !
Euh c'est moi Romain
Excusez moi j'ai tué quelqu'un et je sais pas où cacher le corps ?
Euh peut être sous le lit
À droite
OK pose tout de suite ce biscuit apéritif
Excusez moi ! Je cherche la rue Vaugirard ?
Bon, je fais un truc plus important là !
Y'a vos voisins qui aimeraient bien que vous vous arrêtiez de vous amuser
Parce qu'ils voudraient bien regarder l'émission Motus tranquillement
Est-ce que tu peux comprendre ça ?
Est-ce que tu peux comprendre ce que j'viens te d..
Bah ah bah Michel !
Bah t'es pas au PMU ?
Bref ne laissez pas les gâcheurs de soirées gâcher vos soirées hein, tout simplement
N'oubliez pas que ces gens là c'est vraiment "des fils de pute"
Et puis peu importe la qualité de la soirée
Le plus important c'est d'être avec des gens qu'on aime
Et de kiffer la vie
Voilà mettez un petit pouce en l'air si vous avez aimé
Et si vous allez en soirée... Bah bonne soirée !
Vive la fête !
Ta gueule !
Un Fifa au calme
Un petit chocolat chaud, je t'ai pris ta réplique
*RIRES*